hey everybody it's Mike for your here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmmccontrol
au.l2-3.3.9 limit management of audit
logging functionality to a subset of
privileged users
[Music]
so hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all this cmfc
dfars and nist SP 800171 compliance
stuff on top of an already colossal
workload well I got great news for you
you found your home here at on-call
compliance Solutions we can help you
transform into your company's on-call
compliance hero and learn some new dad
jokes let's jump into it so in cmmc
control
au.l2-3.3.9 limit management of audit
logging functionality to a subset of
privileged users this control is all
about limiting access to only those
people who really need it again there's
a recurring theme throughout nist sp800
171 it's basically all about making sure
that people only have access to what
they actually need access to and if they
don't have access to anything else so as
they say too many chefs in the kitchen
doesn't make for a better tasting cake
or something so only those people who
really need to see seam information
should have access to it so let's check
out what the assessor is looking for on
this one in order to bake them a cake
they'll love to eat all right so two
things you're looking for on this one
number one determine if a subset of
privileged users are granted access to
manage audit logging functionality and
make sure it's defined okay so uh if we
were to give a sample answer we would
say something like uh Hey look it's
implemented because the seam solution is
only accessible by specific authorized
seam administrative users so if you had
a standalone steam system that might be
an answer if you had active directory
maybe you had some kind of a you know
accessible through domain credentials
you might say only this the people in
this certain OU have access to get to
the seam unit but one way or another you
have to actually determine if the subset
is defined so who are those people
that's what they're looking for now
assessment Point number two determine if
management of audit logging
functionality is limited to the defined
a subset of privileged users so in other
words
you have to determine if the actual
management of the functionality right so
the settings configurations things like
that can only a certain subset of those
people see the settings configuration
Etc so again there's the management of
audit logging functionality then there's
actually the management of uh there's
there's the management audit logging
function I was limited to Define subset
of proposal users so who can actually
change settings and things like that all
right now if I was to give a sample
that's that second piece it's really the
same answer as the first piece right
it's just it's more of the same you're
limiting the people who actually have
access to it so again we'd say
implemented the same solution is only
accessible by specific authorized team
administrative users and again if you
had an assessor on your hands you'd
probably just have them look over your
shoulder log into your seam system and
show them all the cool settings how the
magic happens all right now if you're
looking for more magic to happen guess
what you're in the right place because
in on call we work with defense
contractors just like you who have had
this defars nist itar and cmmc compliant
stuff dropped in their laps like a
seagull on a sunny day and we teach you
how to level up and be a proper on-call
compliance hero for your company
eliminating gaps gray areas getting this
solved all while showing you how to
leverage compliance is your secret
weapon to land more Defense work with
higher profit margins now that's what
becoming an on-call compliance hero can
do for you and if you're looking for
more help getting compliant our
compliance experts are always on call
for you visit cmmc compliance
secrets.com or check out the bio below
for links to get help right now if you
love the content we're putting out here
for you help us out with a big thumbs up
on that like button or even better you
guessed it baby smash that subscribe
button to get the latest compliance
content as soon as our compliance errors
roll it out until the next compliance
tip my friends stay safe and secure out
there and hit us in the comments below
to let us know what you'd like to know
more about when it comes to information
security and compliance and I'll see you
on the next one
[Music]
foreign